busy hour of breaking news president
trump set to hold a news conference
he's expected to address his latest
comments about mail-in voting
the president warning of an election day
disaster if everyone votes by mail
you could have a case where this
election won't be decided on the evening
of november third absolutely this
election could work we decided two
months later
maybe two months but what's wrong with
the proper mailing decided many months
later have you discussed
you know why because people lots of
things will happen during that period of
time
especially when you have tight margins
lots of things can happen
there's never been anything like this
when you try now of course
right now we have to live with it but
we're challenging it in many courts
you're going to go all over the country
but this morning the president
encouraging mail-in voting in florida
saying that that state system is safe
and secure
and the other big 2020 story line will
joe biden
step on the debate stage some on the
left say
he should not but his wife dr jill biden
telling dana today that joe will be
there
she also defended against attacks on her
husband's cognitive ability and
claims that he is too far left you know
uh joe is anything but that
characterization
um you know we've been campaigning we've
been listening to the
expert the scientists and the doctors
and they have told us
stay home and be safe and um i think
donald trump is really about joe's age
right
i think there's like two or three years
you know joe's a moderate
and that doesn't mean that his ideas
aren't progressive and bold and forward
thinking
but he's he's not someone who's left
he's not someone who's right he's a
moderate and that's who he's always been
okay shame on dr jill biden for dodging
waters world
we're going to give her a pass i
understand why she did that
uh dana what did you think about the
campaign sending
jill biden out there to make the case
for her husband and how do you think she
did
well i do i always think that a spouse
can be somebody who
gives you another look at the candidate
or a different fee look and feel
for who you're um possibly going to be
voting for in the fall or who your
favorite candidate is going to be
running against um and i think that is
true of melania trump who is
just a fantastic partner for the
president and um so dignified and
gracious and so obviously so
so beautiful and she has that joy when
she sees children i think back to
michelle obama i think she is she
i think the most popular person in the
world i think her popularity laura bush
was a great help
to george w bush and i think that the
reason jill biden is out today
her book is uh coming out it's well it's
a paperback edition of
where where the light enters is the name
of the book so i read that and i had a
chance to talk to her i think it's
interesting when she says
the question i asked her was about the
trump campaign attack that
donald trump believes joe biden is an
empty vessel for the far left
and her instinct and her answer is that
joe biden is a moderate
and yet joe biden also says that he will
be the most progressive president
in history um and i i think that they do
see themselves as moderate
possibly in policy and maybe even in
tone the other thing she said is that
they are
close and then she said he is close on a
vice presidential choice
well they can be both moderate and
progressive it just depends on who you
believe
greg gutfeld there's an interesting
phenomenon that i've noticed with the
media if i've noticed it i'm sure you've
noticed it
i call it the three card monty so well
the media will report something
like you know mail-in balloting is is
bad or dangerous or can lead to delays
trump will say it can be bad dangerous
and lead to delays
and then the media will say oh no
trump's fear-mongering and making things
up about mail-in balloting
and they do this with everything they
think they just did it with the will joe
biden debate thing
no it's once once trump actually says
something that they might agree with
they have to take the uh
uh the opposing side though i'm really
offended
by jill biden and i think dana you could
agree with me that don't you hate people
who only do your show
if they can sell a book it's disgusting
yeah by the way i don't want anybody
like that
yeah i do want to congratulate dana on
winning the mess
the miss pepto bismol 2020 fashion
spread
for the third year running i knew as
soon as i put this dress on
this is your least favorite color it's
your least favorite shade of pink
i am sorry for that but if you could
send me some
pink bubble gum that would be great
i would but unfortunately i'm trapped
because two trees have fallen and i
can't leave my house
which is amazing but that's a different
concern it always happens to me
but okay here the concern for male male
in voting is real
but you can't keep switching baiting it
with uh bait and switching it with
absentee
this is a compat uh capacity issue and a
scrutiny issue it's not an
it's not a corruption issue so you got
to treat it like um
the hospital capacity in covid you got
to
you you got to flatten the curve so the
demand on the postal service
isn't overwhelming the problem is it's
too late even they will admit it's too
late
and a lot of these ballots aren't going
to be counted so we should all agree
democrats or republicans that this isn't
about corruption it isn't about
incompetence
it's about capacity and scrutiny and
we're all going to be screwed
now just to the point about the debates
if i i believe that the democrats are
going to start attaching conditions
to the debates to make it uh harder for
uh
for uh trump to beat buying for for
example they're gonna have the debates
be finished by 4 p.m
uh before it gets you know dark and uh
before the the
turkey soup gets cold uh you can phone
three friends
uh it'll be multiple choice uh you can
wear an earpiece
and there has to be replenished bowls of
ribbon candy
[Laughter]
okay well you know i do want to take
issue with one thing there is a
corruption component
greg and i'll ask juan to address that
perkins co
you know the law firm that hillary paid
to
get that dirty dossier done by the
russians
so this same law firm now is suing a
whole bunch of states
to make it so they can have ballot
harvesting in the election and ballot
harvesting means
someone besides you can deliver your
mail-in ballot
to the place where it's counted so they
could have paid
partisan political operatives picking up
ballots
in the bundles from apartments or from
nursing homes and then bringing them to
where they're supposed to be counted
that's like asking the democrats to do
this on the honor system
in an election where trump's presidency
is on the line
i'm sorry juan i just don't trust it
uh well you know what you should in fact
be encouraging at the idea that someone
would help
folks that are senior citizen's home get
their ballots counted because the ballot
not only has to be signed it has to have
the proper address there are all these
safeguards in place jesse the question
and we just heard it raised by greg is
about the magnitude of the mail-in vote
and so what you want to do is just to
make sure that people get their ballots
to the proper place to be
counted but you know that the thing we
started off today is my concern
trump here is tweeting that it's safe
and secure
to do a mail-in ballot in florida well
wait a second
wait a second he's been sending out all
these signals about how it's not safe
and secure
to do mail-in ballots well how's it safe
and secure all of a sudden in florida
but not in any other state when there's
been no evidence of any kind of fraud
anywhere
so i've got to think that he just he
just concludes
that it's okay if he thinks he can win
the state
and i think he thinks he can win florida
well i think now in the axios interview
hang on i'm finishing in the axios
interview
he seems to make a distinction between
mail-in ballots
and absentee belts but there's no such
distinction they're the same
thing people who say you know what i
i'm an absentee voter i'm going to send
in my ballot that's a mail inbound this
whole thing
is a ruse it's intended to inspire
cynicism
and distrust of the election so that
trump can raise a ruckus
and say this isn't a fair election when
he loses juan are you saying that you
juan williams of fox news you don't know
the difference between an absentee and a
mail-in ballot is that what you're
saying
i'm certain there is no difference well
it depends on this
it isn't clear in the states i mean in
some states
mail-in ballots some that some governors
are talking about
sending ballots to everybody and asking
them to mail them back in
but there are some states that will ask
for if you want an absentee ballot
sometimes you have to have an excuse
other states you don't have to have an
excuse like in texas you have to have an
excuse other states are like just
if you want an absentee just say right
so you have to
right so what you just heard jesse
jesse what you just heard was there's no
difference
no no the difference is juan for an
absentee
you have to go out and request that
ballot be sent to your address
mailing list jesse jesse jesse
in most stations
and the difference in florida is the
republicans have cleaned up
the voter rolls and they're going to get
out yeah
about who they're sending those ballots
to that's the difference jesse that is
just
nonsense let me just explain no let me
explain if you raise this issue let me
explain it to you jesse
you've got enough you have most you have
several states that say
you have to request but most they say
it's universal at this point
now
anytime you hear democrats ranting and
raving and hyperventilating and
clutching their pearls and getting the
vapors
about something that trump has said it's
a plan necessary distraction
because he's on to something these
liberal states
are flailing and failing and totally
incompetent when it comes to what
they're planning
and that is a mass mailing in many
states
of ballots in an unprecedented number
where they have
no way of figuring out oh did we send
him to somebody who moved out of state
oh did we send multiple ballots to
people oh
did the dead get ballots how many
ballots were sent to
a family of one was it five was it ten
these states have no idea what they're
doing
and donald trump has called him on it so
they're gonna make it about
him and then the media they're just the
ventriloquist
dummy for the liberal leaders across
this country
they've been talking about donald j
voldemort
for years and they're just still down
that path if you believe in the
integrity of this election
and you've been able to go to a grocery
store during this pandemic
put your mask on line up and vote like
we always do